[Music]
from calorie count to portion sizes we
wanted to find out the difference
between a us and a uk kfc this is food
wars
now you can't actually get a small drink
at a uk kfc it starts at regular
this is what a regular drink looks like
this is what a us regular looks like and
this
is what a large ring looks like and this
is what a u.s large looks like
this is a regular fries
and this
is a large price
here's the u.s regular
right
you want to go the next size up
this is the u.s large
goods
look at how big that is it's like five
of those ones that he had
let's find out how much a large fryers
weighs in the uk
let's weigh our large fry
oh man
they're packed in there dude look at
that is that everything
this is what a regular popcorn chicken
looks like
we have
a large popcorn chicken and this is what
a large popcorn chicken looks like and
if you want to go even larger than the
large get yourself a popcorn chicken
box
something for you and your buddies i'm
sure
not eating this by yourself
[Music]
did i lose any
no no way am i doing this without oh
don't jinx it
nope
in the uk you can get buckets in three
sizes you can get a six piece
you can get a 10 piece
or you can get a 14 piece
[Music]
eight piece
whoa
12 piece
this is i'm not gonna i can't even dump
it
yo
look how much chicken this is
oh my god a mess
[Music]
unfortunately kfc in the uk doesn't
disclose its ingredients but what we do
know is calories
for example in the uk
a drum
is 170 calories
and in the u.s
one of these guys for the original
recipe is 130 calories but if you get
extra crispy like this guy right here
it's actually 170. usa is actually still
winning on calories that's largely
thanks to the sides and the drinks if
you were to walk into a uk kfc and order
a three-piece meal and they gave you a
drum a thigh and a wing with a large
fries and a large pepsi that would come
to
1155 calories
our large fry is 930 calories and our
large drink is 380. and if you were to
order a three-piece with a large fry and
a large drink in the u.s it would be
roughly this many calories
the kfc in the u.s has released its
ingredients list i would like to go over
the ingredients of the french fries at
the kfc in the u.s all right here we go
sea salt monosodium glutinomate
maltodextrin salt dextrose vegetable
powders try calcium phosphate hydrolyzed
soy proteins spices soybean oil natural
flavors potassium chloride paprika
extract color turmeric extract color
potatoes obviously vegetable oil it has
soybean oil canola cottonseed and or
sunflower uh beached beached bleached
wheat flour and it contains two percent
or less of rice flour durum weed whoa
somolia semolina samole semolina durum
wheat
somolia samolina i don't know what that
word is it looks like it's easy but it's
hard to say semolina semolina dermweed
semolina there you go dextrin salt
degermed yellow cornmeal oh thank god
it's been determined cornstarch leavings
sodium acid pyrophosphate sodium
bicarbonate dextrose again xantham gum
there is a natto extract color the
sodium dihydrox disodium
dihydrogen
pyrophosphate in parentheses to maintain
color okay we add so many chemicals to
our fries we add more chemicals to make
it look like it doesn't have any
chemicals thank you
to sodium
dehydrated
yeah whatever
[Music]
here are some things you can only find
on the menu at a uk kfc so instead of a
chicken sandwich what we call ours is
the chicken philip burger i think it's
pretty much the same thing it's like
breaded and fried chicken between two
buns with some lettuce and some
mayonnaise we also have something called
the zinger burger which is pretty much
the same thing but the spice level is
amped up a little bit you can also turn
these burgers into a tower burger what
that does is adds cheese and a hash
brown to the burger which in my opinion
very worthwhile addition we have some
stuff on our kfc they can't get in the
uk and surprisingly some things i
thought were like kind of
like paramount to the kfc menu mashed
potatoes and gravy this to me seems like
something that has just always been part
of kfc along with the chicken look at
his mashed potatoes man it's a tub of
mashed potatoes okay let's make a mess
oh yeah
oh my goodness put that on the cover of
gravy aficionado magazine
another thing i didn't realize you guys
don't have
biscuits or as you call them scones this
is called a famous bowl it is mashed
potatoes and gravy and corn topped with
popcorn chicken topped with cheese all
in one bowl uh yeah this thing i don't
think i've ever had one of these
because it looks
ridiculous now joe i'm glad you also
think that the famous bowl doesn't go
that great because to me that looks like
a nightmare now we have a slightly
different approach to sides in the uk
compared to the us for example our corn
comes on the cob
baked beans these are slightly different
to the regular beans that you might put
on toast in the uk they have kind of a
barbecue sauce flavor to them there's a
few other language differences like
instead of chicken tenders we call ours
chicken mini fillets
mini fillets chicken tenders they look
exactly the same we got those
yes they have corn but we have ours off
the cob which i think is
um
not as good as on the cob this pile
right here
and i know they do have wings at kfc in
the uk yes i know but only in the u.s
can you order them by 48
[Laughter]
48 wings
i'm dying right now man
you smell so good
the pot pie
when i saw pot pie in the menu i was
like yeah a little side pot pie no dude
this thing is like a puppy this thing
has kind of got some weight to it
i gotta say the pot pie actually looks
quite good we love meat pies here in the
uk you'll often see people tucking into
like a steak and kidney pie or a chicken
pie but yeah they should probably put
that on the menu over here i think
they'd cash in on the british market
let's talk sauces it's sauce talk sauce
talk
i think that uh these sauces are also
specific only to the us and not the uk
the kfc finger looking good sauce
see that
we also have the summertime barbecue
sauce
uh honey mustard
and of course buttermilk ranch
there are a few sources which are
exclusive to the uk for example we have
this spicy supercharger dip which is
kind of like a spicy mayo type thing we
have some sweet chili sauce garlic
mayonnaise another really good option
garlic mayo on chips is just fantastic
why don't we have those sauces here
oh man i want those now usually we'd
have even more exclusive menu items to
show you but unfortunately uk kfc is
currently operating with a reduced menu
here's what you could normally find on
the menu at a uk kfc
a vegan burger the big daddy burger
a range of chicken wraps
some rice boxes onion rings
curry sauce
crushems
and a full range of hot drinks including
english breakfast tea
at the uk you can get
teas
including uh english breakfast tea now
technically you can't get tea
at the kfc's in the u.s but you can get
something called mountain dew sweet
lightning which i think
is probably pretty close
yeah that's pretty much exactly the same
as a breakfast tea
[Music]
dude
[Music]
you